that's right because as we know that
money doesn't grow on trees that's one
of the lessons that we have from
economics and a lot of this stuff costs
money not doing tax credit casts that
costs money if you're doing any kind of
giveaways if you're not cutting spending
by as much as expected that also costs
money and the transfers done both of
those two things and yet at the same
time he says he's going to be borrowing
less than he was last time so how does
he manage that well I'll show you two
charts they explained it these come
directly from the OB ours own documents
the Office of Budget Responsibility this
is a document they've put together this
shows you anything above the line
represents money Biggs basically being
spent and that pushes up boring so
anything above zero is extra boring
anything below it is money that you're
raising so kind of cutting borrowing by
raising tax and stuff like that and have
a look for instance at 2017-18 this year
here now look at the top part of this
the red bit there that red bit
represents the tax credits cut not
coming in so that costs a bit of money
it goes up you see this bit here as well
the gray blue bit that represents not
cutting spending as much so again that
costs money but that's offset by the
fact that the government is raising a
bit of tax that yellow bit it's raising
a little bit of tax through things like
the apprentices levy and stamp duty but
it's not quite enough is it if you see
this bit is a lot smaller than the bit
on top which means that net the
government is spending a bit more money
borrowing a bit more money this costs
money so how does it manage to do this
it's about a six billion when you kind
of take this bit away from the top how
does it manage to do that six billion
extra boring while at the same time
saying that when everything when all is
considered its borrowing less well it's
all because of this and I said it just a
moment ago money doesn't grow on trees
but there is actually a bit of a magic
tree here with in Whitehall and it's
called the office for budget
responsibility it has changed its
assumption for how much tax is going to
be generated by the economy that's the
six point three billion pounds of extra
spending the government is
doing as a result of all of the things
that's decided today this and I remember
same again more spending less money this
is extra tax revenue that the obr now
thinks is coming in so it changed its
forecasts its assumption for how much
tax is being generated by the economy
and as a result of this a massive slug
if you add up all of these things that
comes to 27 billion pounds of extra cash
coming in from the obr for george
osborne to spend Conway